it's fun taking the trip down memory
lane for brain quigan way back in the
day the Sports Nutrition Company and I
say Sports Nutrition cuz turns out
Americans did not want to be smarter at
all uh so selling something for
improving cognition at that point didn't
work at all but I got reports back this
is when as very high touch from athletes
especially NCAA athletes who bought it
for studying they're like yeah I don't
really care about the studying though
but it improved my time off the blocks
for my track event it helped me with
this helped me with that and being the
idiot that I was I ignored that for ages
I was like no this is brain Quicken
right in my own head so I kept pounding
my head against a brick wall didn't work
and eventually I was like wait a second
they're using this for sports the only
reason I spent so much money on my
supplementation as a percentage of my
income is cuz I cared about sports
performance really and then pivoted and
that's when the whole thing took off but
that's not the takeaway that I was going
to share what I was going to share is at
the very earliest stages I had a website
up which a coworker at work at Tran had
put together for next to nothing right
because we were always scheming and we
were always just like going out to lunch
and bullshitting we were friends so I
paid him but I couldn't pay him much he
was like it's fine and he put together a
website for
me I had not manufactured anything I had
done quite a bit of basic math to figure
out if the economics would work nothing
fancy though it's like how much do I
think I could manufacture this for what
are some of the basic cost of sourcing
da da landed on a retail price and at
this point nothing has been made nothing
has been manufactured there's no product
to ship and I just went to co-workers
who were friends and asked them if they
would and it wasn't exactly guilting but
these people at that point didn't really
need this necessarily like it could be a
benefit but I was like Hey I want to try
this out like would you be willing to
just pray for one of these so that I can
try to do a first manufacturing run and
they're like yeah sure why not you know
50 bucks or something at the time and
that gave me just the bare minimum of
capital to start having conversations I
love that and then I had to negotiate
everything right because I would go to
these contract manufacturers and they're
like well our minimum order size is this
and in my head I'm like impossible
that's never going to work and then
they're like and our minimum term of
commitment is this I was like y also
impossible and so I had to sell the
vision and at that time I was able to
because I'd learned through cold calling
off hours get a hold of the president of
this manufacturer got him on the phone
at one point and I was just like I know
at some point somebody gave you a break
I'm not asking for anything other than
can I drive to you at any time and just
tell you about my vision for this
business
and if we are able to find a way to work
together which I would like to I promise
you that I will work with you
exclusively as a manufacturer as we grow
the business went down and I think he
was maybe just amused more than anything
else and he's like okay sure like after
all was said and done and then I used
them for years right and that's how the
deal got done but it all hinged on in
the very beginning the pre-sales yeah
right and also I was buying I mean
negotiating at that time you want to
talk about a real pain in the ass
magazine advertisements feedback loop is
really slow right after you have put out
the cash for the advertising you might
not know what you're selling for months
it could take a really really long time
and so what I did when I started getting
more ambitious because I started with
small ads of course then once I got to
kind of full page ads I would go
to say
Distributors and I would say I would
love to feature you exclusively in this
particular ad but for that to work I
would just need you to to pre-order x
amount of inventory so they buy x amount
of inventory let's say that's
$10,000 and I would also say like it's
$10,000 but the the rate card for this
full page is like 40 Grand and they'd be
like okay well seems reasonable
especially since we're going to make a
profit on the product then I would buy
the ad space as Remnant so I would
negotiate last minute I would get that
for like five grand so what has happened
if I had them pre-order let's say 10K I
paid five I'm already in the black no
matter what the outcome of the
advertisement right and this is the kind
of stuff most entrepreneurs are going to
have to do on some level something like
that